it's happened again
another attack on the u.s capitol
at approximately 102 hours this
afternoon
a suspect entered what we refer to
as the north barricade of the capitol
the suspect rammed his car
into two of our officers and then
hit the north barricade barrier
at such time the suspect exited the
vehicle
with a knife in hand our
officers then engaged he did not respond
to verbal commands
the suspect did start lunging toward
u.s capitol police officers at what
at which time u.s capitol police
officers
fired upon the suspect
at this time the suspect has been
pronounced
deceased the unnamed suspect rammed his
car into two capitol police officers
before hitting the steel barricade
two u.s capitol police officers were
transported to two different
hospitals and it is with a very
very heavy heart
that i announced one of our officers
has succumbed to his injuries
less than three months ago another
member of the capitol police force died
after trying to battle back
a pro-trump mob attempting to stop the
election
in that case reinforcements took hours
but thousands of national guard troops
have been here since just after the
january 6th attack
and they quickly surrounded the building
alert for a follow-up attack
that didn't come congress is not in
session police say they didn't have
any intelligence on this suspect so now
they look to find his motive
most of the fences that have surrounded
the capitol since the attempted
insurrection have been taken down
there were thousands fewer soldiers
walking the grounds
there was a sense that life here was
going back to something approaching
normal
not now not after another deadly day
in front of the symbol of american
democracy
patty culhane al jazeera washington